this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the only one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit can money
truly bring you happiness well if you
ask King Croesus then the answer is a
resounding yes he ruled over the kingdom
of Lydia at a time when it was one of
the wealthiest and most powerful
kingdoms on the planet he amassed untold
riches the likes of which the world had
never seen he spared on the world
economy by even issuing the first gold
coins and yet it all came crashing down
in the end ever fickle fortune abandoned
Croesus and he witnessed his once mighty
kingdom crumble to dust and become just
a small part of an even bigger more
powerful Empire and if Oracle's are to
be believed this had all been part of a
prophecy over 100 years in the making as
Croesus had been destined to pay for the
sins of his ancestors
[Music]
the early years of creases will forever
remain shrouded in mystery as with many
other ancient historical figures one of
our main sources will again be Herodotus
who actually focused the beginning of
his very first book on the history of
Croesus but even Herodotus did not have
much to say about the Lydian before he
became King and as is always the case
with ancient texts there is gonna be
some legend mixed in with truth so well
let's just throw in a pinch of salt
crisis was born circa 595 BC and would
go on to rule over Lydia a kingdom
located in Asia Minor or Anatolia as we
know it today the kingdom itself is an
enigma as no literature or monuments
with extensive inscriptions have
survived what we do know of Lydia comes
to us secondhand from the Greeks the
name is derived from lead us an early
king of Lydia who ruled some time during
the 2nd millennium BC he was part of the
first of three dynasties that ruled over
the kingdom VIII may only I how many
there are how long they ruled how they
lost power we have no idea but at one
point they were replaced by the
Heraclitus T so-called because they
claim to be descendants of Hercules and
Alvin we have a little more information
thanks again to good old reliable
Herodotus not really Roger sometimes
just make stuff up he said that the
Heracles ruled over Lydia for 22
generations or 505 years with a son
succeeding his father each time we only
know the names of three of them relevant
to us today was only the last King King
candalas also known as merciless to the
Greeks the story of how he lost power is
a fascinating one that merits repeating
even if it might just be a better legend
after all it is not every day that a
powerful dynasty is brought down by
voyeurism condole is had a beautiful
wife named monsieur and she wasn't just
beautiful she was apparently one of the
most stunning creatures to ever walk the
earth
at least all that's what candalas
thought at first you might think this
was rather sweet AM am so deeply
enamored with his wife but the king
raved about Nia's beauty to anyone and
everyone who would listen particularly
his bodyguard and most trusted servant
guy jeez one day the king was going on
about his wife to guy jeez and looking
at his body card he detected a whiff of
skepticism because a scan
as thought a man trusts his eyes more
than his ears the king decided that guy
Gees must seen a seer naked so that he
may be convinced that she was indeed the
most beautiful woman in the world guy
G's was shocked when he heard and
pleaded with the king but at the end of
the day candalas was his master so if he
wished it it had to be done then nights
the king took his bodyguard into the
Royal chambers and had him hide behind a
door
misiek Amon took off her clothes and got
into bed with her husband's guide he's
witnessed the whole thing and then tried
to sneak out but the Queen saw him and
instantly realized what had happened
this year felt deeply ashamed and
decided that she needed vengeance the
next day she called guy G's to see her
and he came voluntarily because he had
not realized that he had been spotted
the night before missio gave him a
choice either kill himself or kill his
master become King and take her as his
new wife so his options were essentially
to die or become richer powerful to
marry one of the most beautiful women in
the world it was a hard decision but in
the end guy G's work with option B the
Queen brought him into her sleeping
chambers just like the king did the
night before the bodyguard waited for
his master to fall asleep and then he
stabbed him with a dagger gayatri's took
over the throne and founded the mum the
dynasty it should be noted that this is
just one of multiple stories of how the
Heraclitus fell in another version by
Plato guy G's was a shepherd who took
the power with the help of a magic rings
that made him invisible but that one's
little less likely some modern
historians adopt a more practical
viewpoints and believe that gonzales was
simply assassinated because he had
become unpopular with the people
unsurprisingly not everyone was happy
with the saying of canned Ali's and his
death prompted a minor civil war
however Nasir managed to quell the
uprising pretty fast by decree that they
should all heed the decision of the
Oracle of Delphi
if the CL ordained guy G's to be the new
king of the Lydians then he would assume
power if not then it would be handed to
the Heraclitus the Oracle sided with
Ganges but Divine's that the Heraclitus
would have their vengeance after five
generations the Magna Dai rules Lydia
with great success for a hundred and
forty years during the reign of the 4th
King Ali at is the Kingdom covered most
of Western Asia Minor but in 550 BC Ali
eighty's died and he was succeeded by
his son
the fifth-generation MERM nerd Croesus
aly artis was a very powerful and
successful king who ruled for almost 60
years during that time he waged many
wars to increase the reach of his
kingdom particularly against the Greek
city-states in Asia Minor to the east of
the kingdom was the median Empire who
also fought against the Lydians however
in 585 BC while the two kingdoms were
warring there was a solar eclipse today
known as the Eclipse of Daly's both
sides took it as an omen and declared a
truce soon after after a treaty was
signed the Haley's River became the
official border between the two empires
and the two kingdoms even arranged a
royal marriage helped solidify the new
peace the Lydian princess offered her
marriage was crisises older sister arias
who married the king of media are stewar
gays Croesus did not know it yet but
this new relation would later a force
him into a war that would bring on his
doom Croesus is rise to the throne was
not without incident he had clearly been
positioned as his father's heir when he
was given the governorship of an
important city called ad remit ium this
post was traditionally assigned to these
successors so that he may receive some
administrative experience before
assuming the mantle of king however when
a yachties died and Lydia was getting
ready to accept Croesus as its new king
his authority was challenged by a
half-brother named Kant early on a
1-point greasiest was even the target of
a conspiracy and barely escaped being
poisoned by his stepmother we do not
know the details of the sibling rivalry
but obviously in the end creases
prevailed and assumed kingship of Lydia
when he was 35 years old as soon as he
was certain in his role King Croesus
resumes the favorite habit of his father
which was to fight his neighbors his
first target was a thesis a Greek city
on the Ionian coast located a couple of
miles from where the modern Turkish city
of Celtic is today the city's main claim
to fame was its temple dedicated to the
goddess Artemis which had been destroyed
by a flood sometime during the seventh
century BC Croesus conquered a thesis
around 560 BC and he sponsored at least
partially the rebuilding of the Temple
of Artemis making it bigger and more
opulent than it was before it was
described as being over 330 feet long
having 40-foot tall columns and being
made mostly of marble this of course
would go on to be known as one of the
seven wonders of the world but by the
time such list started making the rounds
in the Greek world the temple had
actually been destroyed and rebuilt once
more around the mid fourth century BC a
man named hero Stratos set it on fire
the arsonist was obsessed with Fame and
wanted people to know his name at all
costs what better way to do this than
destroy one of the most beautiful things
in the world the Ephesians caught
tortured and executed here a Stratos but
also sentenced him to damnation the more
I the condemnation of memory where he
was stricken from every official record
so that his name may be forgotten by
history after all what better punishment
could there be for someone who wanted to
be remembered as it all costs
unfortunately for the Ephesians their
plan did not work as a Greek historian
named Theia Pampas recorded the event
since today we still remember the name
and actions of hera Stratos so let's go
back to Croesus once the thesis was
conquered he simply moved on from one
target to the next he didn't rest until
all the Greek cities on mainland Asia
Minor were either part of his kingdom or
paid tribute to him so it happens that
Croesus subjected all of the people west
of the Haley's River the accepts the
Silesians and the license
afterwards he shifted his focus to the
nearby islands in the Aegean Sea and
intended to conquer them as well in the
end though he decided against it the
Lydian army was famed for its horseback
soldiers who of course would be
completely useless in naval warfare
instead Croesus made friends with Greek
island nations now maybe you're watching
this video and you're thinking wow I
sure would like to be the richest person
who ever lived someday like Croesus well
that brings me right into today's
sponsor Squarespace now I can't promise
you that setting up your Squarespace
website and selling something online is
gonna get you there but hey you don't
know unless you try and without two
things maybe you've got some idea for a
website or a business or a youtube
channel a podcast something like that
it's knocking around in your mind well -
the only way you're gonna figure out
whether that is worth doing is to get it
out there to the world and that can be
daunting because you know it's scary to
pursue new things but not knowing how to
set up a website is not an excuse there
are no excuses available with
Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create
powerful website for whatever you're up
to want to sell something online yes
easy to set up a store with Squarespace
so you want to do a podcast start a
YouTube channel well you'll want a
website to complement those things
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or
easily start from scratch or just move
over from an existing domain making
everything super easy to manage and once
you've gone through the easy
customization process there's no updates
there's no patches there's no tech BS to
deal with and Squarespace they also
handle all of that website II stuff they
do podcasts mailing lists social media
integrations it's all there like I say
no excuses with Squarespace just go get
started do it today head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm /nya graphics and
you'll save 10% of your first purchase
of a website or a domain and let's get
back to it
unsurprisingly all his conquests made
Croesus a very rich man in fact he was
probably among the richest men in
history
besides the tributes he received from
the Greek cities the Kings vast wealth
also came from abundant mineral deposits
located throughout lydia particularly in
sardis the kingdom's capital the
expression as rich as Croesus is still
in use today thousands of years after he
died his massive wealth aside Croesus
had another claim to fame which ensured
his role in the history of economics the
introduction of coins the Lydian King is
credited with issuing the first ever
gold and silver coins these had a
standardized purity and a fixed exchange
rate between various denominations and
between the gold and silver variants
these coins were called crows oyster
Terry's in ancient documents although
today we simply refer to them as crow
seeds they depicted a lion and a bull
the use of coins period is generally
ascribed to Lydia although about a
hundred years or so before the
introduction of crises this claim is a
bit more controversial there was some
historical text say that the other
places were first although still in the
same region some sources claim the city
of Argos used coins first or the Greek
islands of Aegina which had the silver
stated depicting a turtle if the Lydians
were not first they were definitely
among the earliest adopters though their
original coins just like the Greek
status were made of electrum an alloy of
gold and silver that occurs naturally
these coins were definitely in use
during the reign of Ali Arty's but they
were not practical enough for day-to-day
spending even the smallest denominations
were still too valuable to buy something
trivial like a loaf of bread for example
this changed during creases this time
according to Herodotus again he was not
only the first to introduce gold and
silver coins but also the first to use
them to sell goods by retail
while the original Lydian coins weight
above 10 grams Croesus issued a wide
range of small denominations going all
the way to 148 of a gram this made it
possible for Lydians to use coins in
their daily shopping trips and in case
you were wondering how the Lydians
determines the purity of a coin they
used a tool called a touchstone it was
simply a piece of dark stone made out of
slate or field stone or other rocks with
a finely grained surface on which soft
left a trace they took recording with an
unknown gold purity and rubbed it
against the touchstone so it left a
streak they then compared the streak to
others made with coins of known purity
and simply looked for a color match the
fact of the creases was a conquering
warlord only served to expedite the
spread of coins they were used in all
the Greek cities that he subjugated from
the Greeks it spread to the Romans who
spread it to the rest of Europe when
Lydia was conquered by the Persians it
spread to Mesopotamia when the Persians
were conquered by Alexander the Great he
spread it even further and so it went
until coin usage became a standard
across the globe Croesus seemed to live
by the creed of if you got it then
flaunt it after all what was the point
of being the richest man in the worlds
if he couldn't show off his vast wealth
he received many esteemed guests
particularly from the Greek world that
is that part of the Greek world that he
hadn't conquered
he sobbed the fables fable writer was
among his visitors but the most notable
guests to Lydia was Solon the Athenian
statesman who reforms the city's laws
and set the foundations for Athenian
democracy after he finished his
administrative duties so long left
Athens and went on a 10-year trip to see
the world towards this end he arrived in
Sardis where he was graciously greeted
by King Croesus who rolled out the
Welcome Wagon so long was given a tour
of the palace where he saw all of the
gold the silver the precious stones and
other vast riches that Croesus possessed
afterwards the confident King asked his
wise visitor whom he considered to be
blessed beyond all men the answer
probably surprised and even annoyed the
Lydian King surely he was expecting
Solon to say that Croesus was blessed
beyond all others but he didn't the
philosopher concluded that a man named
tellus of Athens had that honor he
reasons the tellus had a good family
full of noble sons and healthy
grandchildren and in his old age he
enjoyed a glorious death in battle
securing a victory for the Athenians
against their neighbors it lusus okay so
Croesus wasn't first but surely he would
claim 2nd place right well not according
to so long he believed that the
runners-up were two brothers from argos
named clear de sand bit on they had a
mother named Sidibe who was the
priestess of Hera
one day she
needed to get into town for a festival
dedicated to the goddess but could not
find the oxen to pull a cart instead of
oil sons yokes themselves build the car
for six miles into Argos when they
arrives in the city the archives gave
the brothers a hero's welcome for their
dedication to their mother and tahira
clear this and bitten then made
sacrifices to the gods age plentifully
and fell asleep in the temple city pay
prayed era that her sons may receive the
greatest boon for the honor they showed
and the goddess agreed Claire bursts and
bit and died peacefully in their sleep
and were allowed to rest for eternity in
the ends so long reasoned that he could
not count Croesus among the truly
blessed until he knew that the king died
well unsurprisingly this angered Croesus
who censored on her way without any
lavish gifts concluding that the old man
was a fool for ignoring his wealth
basically there were two lessons to take
away from Solon stories one that money
wasn't everything and two that fortune
can be fickle and changed suddenly
Croesus of course immediately dismissed
both lessons but he would eventually
learn them the hard way soon after so
long departed sadhus creases had a dream
which showed that his son Attis would be
killed by an iron spear batis was the
heir to the Lydian Kingdom Croesus had
another son but he was deaf and dumb and
Herodotus didn't even bother naming him
fearing this vision the King forbade
addis from leading any Lydian armies
into battle one day he received a plea
for help from the province of Monsieur
which was being attacked by a giant boar
that destroyed the fields and killed the
livestock Croesus allowed at ease to led
an expedition to slay the Beast
after all it was unlikely that the boar
would wield a spear part of that
expedition was a man named Adrastus
former prince from Phrygia who had been
banished by the king after he
accidentally spilled the blood of his
brother as Phrygia was subjected to
lydia King Croesus took Adrastus sin and
purified him of his blood crime in
exchange he tossed addressed as to act
as a toises bodyguard and make sure that
no harm came to him he agreed but ended
up doing the exact opposite during the
fight with the boar addressed us through
the spear and missed the animal but it
hit and killed at us the King cried and
mourned his son lamenting that his
mighty Kingdom no longer had an heir
however soon enough he would have bigger
problems to face as
iris the great was on the warpath he
might recall we said earlier that Lydia
had an alliance by marriage with the
median Empire to the east well in 550 BC
the median Empire didn't exist anymore
it had been conquered by Cyrus the Great
and added to his arc emanate Empire
just like Croesus and many other
warlords before him Cyrus had a lust for
power and wanted to grow his empire he
subjugated all the lands in his path and
it was clear to everyone that he was on
a collision course with the Lydian
Kingdom as one of the only other major
power players in the region plus as the
median Queen was creases his sister he
could not leave this provocation
unanswered by the way if you would like
more detail on the events we already did
a full video on Cyrus the Great so you
can check out the link below and learn
more about the man who became king of
the four corners of the world
Croesus didn't want to back trash so
before he took any course of action he
wanted to consult the Oracles however
the question was which Oracle should he
trust as a test he sent agents to all
the Oracles in the lands they will left
the same day and were to inquire what
King Croesus would be doing a hundred
days later out of all of them the only
two gave answers that satisfied the king
the Oracle of amphiaraus and the Oracle
of Delphi the latter was the same Oracle
that ordained guides to rule Lydia and
also predicted the fall of his dynasty
after five generations we don't know
what the MPR s Oracle said but the
Delphian Xia who is called picea
correctly predicted that on the
hundredth day King Croesus would eat
tortoise and lamb meat boiled in a
bronze cauldron after this prediction
came to pass Croesus made a lavish
offerings at the temple of Delphi he
wanted to know if he should attack Cyrus
since the Pythia gave him perhaps the
most notorious divination in history she
predicted that if Croesus attacked cyrus
he would destroy a great empire
immediately he assumes this could only
mean the Persian Empire so Lydia went to
war as Croesus would later discover the
Oracle was talking about his own the
prophetess also gave the King some
practical advice and told him to seek
out the mightiest of Greeks and make
them his friends that of course would be
Sparta in the end Lydia allied with the
Spartans but also with the Egyptian
and the babylonians how Croesus got each
one to join his war against cyrus were
not sure they were probably all paid off
but some would have also been concerned
with the danger posed by the Persian
Empire growing uninhibited in their
vicinity ultimately the Allies made
little difference to Croesus first he
and Cyrus fought to a stalemate in the
Battle of Metiria in 547 BC afterwards
he was decisively defeated at the Battle
of thim bruh Croesus retreated to the
capital of Sardis hoping to wait out the
Windsor until his reinforcements arrived
cyrus however followed him laid siege on
Sardis and captured the capital after
two weeks just like that Lydia has
fallen and was now part of the
Achaemenid Empire The Fader creases
himself however is more of a mystery
ancient accounts a rather fanciful and
claimed that the god Apollo came down
from Olympus and saved the king before
his execution and consequently Cyrus
accepted him as an advisor shockingly
modern historians don't actually think
this happens and many of them believe
that Croesus did indeed die in 546 BC
after the fall of Sardis either by his
own hands or by being burned on a pyre
according to Herodotus while on the pyre
Croesus cried out the name of Solon
three times only then did he truly
understand what the wise Athenian tried
to teach him that no man is truly
blessed until he dies well because until
then his fortune can change at any time
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below don't forget to
subscribe and please do support this
show by supporting our fantastic sponsor
Squarespace I'm gonna link to below and
thank you for watching
[Music]